hello everybody it's time for me to flex
on your kits again have you seen my view
10 look at this baby it has to pick up
and wake up feature where I literally
don't have to press a button to unlock
it wow it's almost like you don't have
to pay a thousand dollars for this
feature incredible but I know what
you're thinking but Felix what if I have
a psycho girlfriend
who will use it on me when I am asleep
don't worry
that's right it doesn't unlock if you're
sleeping thank God it even covers my
most advanced testing clearly this is
the superior if you want to view ten
we're doing a giveaway that's right
three winners will win a prize pack
which contains one on review ten and an
honor band the honor band works with a
face long lock as well it's got 30 days
usage of one charge incredible
waterproof and tracks your sleeping data
this contest is between April 15 and 20
check out the link in the description
for more info now let's go on with a
video guys you ever see something online
that gives you that expression that
feeling that you just can't express with
words and you just have to go that is
pretty interesting of course you have
but today in case you haven't we're
going to review with some like worthy
moments so we can go together you and me
as a fun little exercise I bet you don't
have any friends let's review the reddit
hmm I hate when they're sexual is this
weird they're not sexual using I'm sorry
I'm sorry I was just kidding it was a
joke it's just water it's just water
now that's sexual mmm how does that make
any this really shows the reflection of
water crisis what am I saying
those are not his eyes those are not
spiders Maine's ice my whole life is a
lie how can I possibly look at
spider-man the same way if he doesn't
look back at me with those spidey eyes I
[Music]
almost died out of who me if the mouse
it's outside of the presentation what's
the mouth even really there this is
social react to this I mean this is a
good Photoshop but it doesn't make me
Mary lying if I said this makes me David
makes me mm here's a bomb defuser and
he's playing minesweeper nothing really
human about it it's more like well
that's funny I suppose now that's
finally I hate guys I hate Twilight I
don't know if I ever expressed this
properly on this channel but Twilight is
just a cringes dumbest vampire show and
doesn't have real superheroes like Black
Panther here this is so nice to finally
see a progressive police woman famine
that carries nut guns but carrots but
who came first the horse or the carrot
[Music]
obviously the carrot like let's not even
be silly here
nice let's freaking this is my song this
is my jam come on guys let's go
I didn't know that actually I see I
wonder if that actually works hmm
you ever wonder why I don't shave okay
this is the reason it's called it's
called not having a proper jawline all
right wow that is interesting that's
nice to see emojis being so progressive
finally we have an emoji for everything
now what the Frick is this this is not
hmm
get your garbage fantasies out of home
okay subsetting Here I am trying to whom
it things and I'm just stuck with this
now this is sexy nice sexy if only
Marcia look like this if only Marcia
would look this good
if only merci
Martha if only Marcia what what am I
supposed to say this is such a dumb
video why did you guys want me to make
another one of these mmm there you go
mmm
see I don't understand when more people
don't do this any time I'm in the Euro
people go as far away from me as
possible but I'm like we could save
water if we all just put our dicks
together
there this is why you shouldn't smoke
kids I mean look at this man
why is him hmm is mixed with such a
strange feeling you know you feel these
urges from booming there's no shame in
feeling that real mm-hmm so that's what
they use for I always thought I should
just put my bag on those that looks
fantastically great okay I don't see
them right away link give me a second
here that's Jesus Christ so much better
whether you don't see it right away how
can I tell if you check Google right now
and you see this exact image then this
is me when I play for tonight cuz these
are all kids
that's right come at me kids what are
you gonna do Jesus Christ stop these
weird photo shops okay no one is humming
at them
[Music]
such a dumb video Jesus Christ no is
that real
no no this is also another reason why
you should never shave okay right here
here now that's him sleepy sleepy this
is a live footage of sleepy traveling
into the other realm
life is so mm-hmm a uniform hmm for
respective sleepy is that those thing
you iron does that mean it's an IRA news
enjoying the book more prime hmm if I
saw a toilet like that I would take down
my pants I would squat down and I would
go hmm so bad I am the worst ah just I
don't know if you guys have heard about
the turtle in the wall theory but this
pretty much confirms that all walls have
a turtle living in them hmm
now that somebody's finally doing right
which one do you make a poopy in hmm
which one would you choose mmm a true
hoon dilemma
mm-hmm a uniform hmm that's right even
lizard people goes home finally we have
some evidence for this he's a robot by
the way open your eyes okay there's
nothing to confirm that he's a lizard
I've seen this this is so insane why did
you have to photoshop this why that's
right every single time I watch Titanic
I'm like he can just go up so stupid
this really shows sexism and how it's
bad for men it's wet damn Daniel he's
rocking it damn he looks good what in
the world hmm
sometimes clothing likes to move back at
you mm-hmm
this is the worst video of all time no
now I can never look at hmm the same way
god damn it this changes everything
what a great idea and you can keep the
trucks running for warm hmm
yeah well how come we never thought of
this before huh
wasn't that just a great experience we
all need a little home in our life don't
you think leave a like if you who
believe you're like if you move and I'll
see you guys next time
in the next video
[Applause]